okay i think we are all set
all right hunt and yvonne yes
so you are nudists yes but you are also
swingers
yes and you are not a couple you're just
you're just two swingers that i
put together you pulled us up off the
pool deck yeah i just i i
sucked you off the uh from different
places yeah we weren't engaged in sex
yeah
you were not engaged in sex you were you
were just having a good day
was in the bar and you were in the pool
yvonne but uh
so tell me about how long have you been
nudists
for me it's about 12 years 12 years 2007
is that about right to math maybe
you know yeah and how did you get
introduced to it
um i was married in a traditional
marriage
for a long time 20 years and um
i suddenly wanted to
i was reading uh about bit bill's
different different lifestyles and um
wanted to find a place where there were
sort of um sociosexual people
in numbers and that is a very difficult
thing to find on the internet from a
beginning
search and for some reason um
nudist places not all not all
most new displaces are are kind of
family friendly but there are some new
displaces that
tend to have a swinger community
clientele
and here here at paradise lakes do you
have both uh yes very much so
uh especially um apparently
back before my time it was a very
lifestyle kind of outpost
post hippie post uh and by lifestyle you
mean swingers swingers
um yeah back if you think sort of after
the sexual revolution of the 60s it sort
of
started in the 80s and was a very party
fun place like that and it's gone up and
down
uh over the years um back and forth sort
of
uh we were anner which is the american
association of
nude recreation and then we weren't and
um
then they some people broke off from
here and built another
resort because we were too lifestyle
is my understanding of history and then
um then they became lifestyle and
apparently it went back and forth sort
of over the years
we're more that way we're more that way
and trying to fight for
the right the right market to please
everybody and um
so we've further i've been here for the
last two owners we just got new owners
and the last two were sort of
ambiguous nudist not lifestyle
sort of lifestyle under the radar but
and um and the new owners
seem to have a bit more of a lifestyle
uh
focus so the swinger aspect will
probably come back
to life i'm very excited about that
actually and yvonne
tell me about your introduction to um so
funny thing is i grew up mormon
i did i tell people that and their
reaction is always the same
really i always um
i was always more open
about things i was never skittish about
what i looked like
and you know i'd walk into a bathroom
and my sister would scream at me
and little things like that and at 19
i was working for the big water park
down here
and my roommate that also worked with me
started dating a gentleman
or a boy that we worked with who lived
here in the back condos with his dad
and they said come on over and just hang
out and it was
five minutes later i found my home and
my roommate and i were on our
rollerblades back and forth
skating around so i've been coming to
paradise off and on since i was 19.
there was a 15-year gap in there um
i got married and he went from
being okay with it to this isn't right
and wasn't okay with it so yeah my
ex-husband
ex-husband so when the divorce
finally got finished i'm like i really
want to be around people that i'm
comfortable with and that i'm happy
being around so i started coming back
off and on and
between here and caliente i lived at
eden for a little while which is another
resort
um it's been a journey coming back to
and finding
myself over the last 10 years so it's
been a way of
helping you to find yourself yes it has
it's been quite a journey
there's been belly dancing there's been
hula hooping there's been
post office there's been self-employed
cleaning but it always revolved around
being comfortable with myself and being
around people that were comfortable
being open and honest and not having
hang-ups over what we looked like and
a lot of a lot of us americans have
hang-ups over
nudity and sex we really really do and
that comes a lot from our media
because in other countries um it's not
really looked at as something that's
as terrible as we make it out to be and
so that's that's my opinion on it i've
known people that grew up as
nudists you know their parents were
nudists and they were kids and they grew
up in this
society in this industry not industry
but this lifestyle and
i mean they're pilots they're attorneys
they're
very well they're doctors they
don't have the hang up when they get to
college you know when you get to college
and you're 20 years old and you're out
on your own and you want to go to the
strip clubs and you want to go to the
bars and
see the boobs and the white t-shirt
contests and and you're
they're going i've already seen all that
i just here to study
so it it you don't have the hang-ups
that you do
that others do when they first go out on
their own because you grew up seeing
naked bodies you're there to learn and
get an education and
it's it's interesting for me uh
as an outsider to look at people and the
guys are letting their guts hang out the
women are letting everything else hang
out nobody cares
that you know it's not about that yep
it's the six inches between here and
here
and once you're here it's very easy to
turn it off because you can see that
nobody really cares you are attractive
to somebody
somewhere they don't care what shape
your body is in
you are attractive self-acceptance seems
to be
it's big big here it really it does help
uh people if you're the more attractive
you are to yourself which you see a lot
of people transform
from feeling not attractive in the
textile world
to feeling more attractive in the nudist
world two things you just said that
triggered me one was found my home
and the other was this lifestyle and
that's tricky because this is not this
is not one lifestyle we're talking about
there's multiple lifestyles there are
multiple and the main two we're talking
about is nudist and swinger
they can coincide they tend to sometimes
but very much people on the outside
they look at us and they think oh you
all are messed up
right a bunch of deviants we were
we grew up the same socio norms
that everybody learns in this
puritanical country right
um but you can be
on learning to accept nudism
is one whole trek and lifestyle you
might not
do both you can be lifestyle and be
completely textile some people here are
uh is it naturists nature yeah right and
who are just purely they like being
naked right
and more so we have an older the
original club
is next door to us and that tends to be
more it's a rustic place with more
people who kind of shun lifestyle they
don't want lifestyle
a lot of the new disclosures again
lifestyle is the swingers
the lifestyles of swingers and and
through history um
nudist clubs have had to fight the
textile world just sort of like
black or people wearing clothing they're
wearing clothing
and and anna has been great at
assisting in that um
i'm both i'm i i do
i consider myself a nudist i'm nude all
the time i live here i work here i drive
to here on my cart
i barely go past target for anything i
barely
put on clothes i'm a nudist and i'll go
hang out with people who are
nudist naturists whatever i'll have a
bonfire we'll play drums
we'll play volleyball whatever but i'm
also a swinger and sometimes
a swinger event i might go to you know
you wear clothes you dress up
it's two completely different things and
people get very confused when we start
it's important to me to say it's not
this lifestyle we're talking about we're
talking about nudism
and we're talking about swinging they're
different and they can go inside
but they each happen without the other
thing
yes yeah yeah it's good that that's
clarified because otherwise it just
becomes like oh there's a bunch of
just a bunch of yeah and the colony in
the swinger colony
when i worked for the post office it was
too funny so um the office that i worked
in there is a nudist resort on the
office
and it was just everyone knew i was on
at work because
they've got somebody you know like oh
you need to deliver this to the nudist
colony oh do i have to go to the gate
and you can hear me clear from the back
of the office resort
i've seen your viewership how many views
you get on some things
listen people it's an ant colony it's a
leopard colony we're
a nudist community or a nudist resort or
both
we're not a colony but oh is that right
in the comments
oh it's it's one it's a pet peeve for us
when people say new this colony it
sounds like a leopard colony and that's
how they view it we're not a colony
we're a community or a resort
or both we're not a column but yeah well
all i know you know because i i'm
looking for like hidden
signs of dysfunction or or weirdness
or or oh you'll find them everywhere but
you'll also find them in the textile
world
no no no no i'm saying it's very i don't
detect a whole lot of that here at all
well i'm sure they're just we keep them
under rocks
over my previous marriage i i it was
a disaster i mean there was it took me
it took me quite a few years to um dig
out from
the mental manipulation i went through
but if i had had any say in it because
of my previous experience before i met
him i absolutely would not have had any
problem raising my kids in a nudist
lifestyle
or nudist home or community because
you grow up knowing that
nobody looks like they do in the
magazines everybody will accept you the
way you are
all you can do is be the best that you
can be at what you're good at
and you probably accept yourself and
absolutely well tricky thing is it's not
nobody because sometimes somebody shows
up
that does look like the people in the
magazines yeah and and
and that gives the contrast i mean
the people who don't have to accept them
just as much
as absolutely you know yeah so if you
think about like a uh
i'm not saying it doesn't happen there
may be a swinger event where they're
trying to just have cannon barbies and
there's some sort of
process to make sure that you're
attractive enough to attend right that
happens
but it does it tends to happen more in
textile world
than in nudist world in nudist world
we're all just hanging out
i find it to be there's there's no idea
but it's the
it's the least judgmental group of
people you'll get together
anywhere i've ever seen and and that
brings me back to finding your home
and marriage so i was very traditional
marriage
uh 20 years
i thanks to the internet began to
realize that there were
other people that thought different ways
i'm just beginning to realize more about
polyamorous
uh relationships which i i always say
that it was kind of like the the ugly
duckling story
the story of the ugly duckling where
when i moved
here i found my i found out i was a swan
and i and i found my people and and i'm
comfortable
with all of them in a way that i never
was now my wife
did not take to it however
with my ex-wife we are divorced we still
live together
same house we're best friends she just
was not
not interested in sociosexual activity
and i was and so my girlfriend lives
with me
in the middle of the house my ex they've
become
best friends we have no sexual
interaction between my girlfriend and i
and my ex-wife
but we're still kind of polly because we
all love each other and support each
other and help each other every day
there's a lot to be said for having more
than one person
that you care about and and and that was
really funny because i've been in
a couple of poly relationships before um
yeah there's a lot to be said about
having more than one person that you can
share
your love with and there's there's a
comment i saw somewhere it's like how is
this possible
well how is it possible for you to be in
love with your husband
and your kids you are capable we are all
capable of loving
more than one person more than i mean
pets i mean
the traditional your fur child you're
you know you love them as much as a
child
how is that normal is that abnormal so
the definition of normal depends on who
you're talking to
and there's no such thing as normal
normals are setting on your washing
machine for crying out loud
you sound much happier today than you
were in your past merit
oh absolutely oh absolutely it took a
lot
there's a lot of therapy there was a lot
of finding
new friends that were
very helpful in getting me out of a
different mindset to being more
independent and not having to take care
of everybody because i'm a caretaker at
heart
so tell me about the swinger aspect of
this
how does that happen i mean like
i'm oh my friends there are events
or so there are parties there have been
i haven't been to too many
i'm i'm busy trying to financially put
myself together because you know i
walked away and i
started over from scratch for everything
so
there are parties i've been to a couple
of them and they're fun
they don't consume my life it's like you
people think that all you think about is
sex excellent every day
every day yeah that would be ideal but
i'm not a millionaire
that's what they think they think too
behind the walls of a nudist resort is
it's an orgy every day oh they're
playing volleyball but it broke out into
an orgy
no no nowadays it's not they're choosing
there's no competitive to do yeah
it's not at work so one of the things
that when i
first met my ex-husband um i i'd always
told him that i'm not a jealous person
and you know i'm going to be
focused on growing or taking care of our
kids or
whatever i don't have a problem because
he used to
go to the strip clubs like go have fun
i'm not a jealous person
he had a hard time with that it was like
i was trying to get
him to do something to make me mad at
him
so he never really did get that i'm
not a jealous person he thought you were
playing a game he thought i was playing
a game which he's very good at playing
games but
that just wasn't my nature i'm still not
a jealous person
finding other people that are okay with
that has been
not difficult but it's been nice finding
other people that it's nice to find a
large group
of people especially your families who
are probably not nudists
how do they react to this so i've told a
few of my siblings i'm the oldest of
eight
i've told a few of them and they're okay
they just don't want to see me naked
that was that's been the comment from
the three that do know it's like
i'm happy for you but we don't want to
see you
i wouldn't mind coming to the place but
we just don't want to see you and i'm
okay with that
i mean they just it doesn't stop me from
being their sister
and they're they accept me i've always
been
the different one anyway
[Laughter]
so i i've been working here for uh at
this resort uh for about
12 years and um
uh my mother came down and
and and stayed short long for short
we had moved to the mississippi gulf
coast
right before katrina and both our homes
got wrecked and
she had always intended she lives up in
massachusetts with my sister and she'd
always intended to come down and
start living in the south start living
in florida and not have those winters
and we had just worked that out and then
katrina ruined all that and so here i am
and she's like
all right that's different but she came
and she stayed like three months
and she found everybody people would you
know she has mobility problems but she'd
come down to the karaoke and sit there
and people would dance with her
and uh she fell in love she's she
has more facebook friends from here than
i do um
she's a nudist no absolutely she stays
here
uh she did for one one summer and meant
to come back finances didn't allow it to
happen things just went bad but um so
she stays with my sister in
massachusetts and my sister who is i've
been the dearest person my whole
my whole life was this hippie that i had
she was about you know seven years older
than me and i
and and i always looked up to her and
admired her and uh and
and we could deal with anything together
and and
when i when she started finding out what
i was doing here
she kind of sort of turned on me a
little bit in a way i or i felt like
and uh now that's over now so now now
she she's just
i don't know she has she's been
acceptable of the idea of coming to
visit
yeah but yeah she's probably not gonna
it's mostly about freedom
it is and somebody like that probably
thinks well i'll go visit but i'm not
gonna get naked
that takes all of five minutes what
happens when you go to a nudist resort
is five ten fifteen minutes later you're
the minority and everybody's staring at
you the way you think you'd be stared at
if you were in you know
walmart when i came out to the pool to
get you yvonne yeah
and apparently is that a cop
i feel like i should be naked yeah yeah
and we don't we're clothing optional no
okay there's another difference so
we're doing this to educate the people
out there so and you're you're learning
and so are the people that are watching
this so you can go to a place
here are the words you want to look for
is it nudist naturist
or is it clothing optional or is it
textile which they don't if you're
textile you don't bother saying it
but clothing optional is what we are
which means you're allowed to come here
and wear your bikini wear shorts as long
as you want
some places will have a thing like well
it's clothing optional unless you want
to get in the pool
you have to be new to get in the pool
and that's kind of more of a
thing for making you know it's better
for the pool equipment not to have the
detergent that's in our clothes that we
wear all day long
we don't but when you wear your clothes
all day long there's detergents and
stuff in them
anyway so this work clothing option
and you have the choice to come here and
observe
and the only problem that creates is if
you get
tends to be single males who are
coming to observe and we have ways of
dealing with that
but um but for the most part you know
women will wear
uh bottoms certain times of the month
um or if you just and when we have a
dance a nightclub we go to the nightclub
oh any chance to dress up seriously
glitter
as much as possible high heels [ __ ] wear
they're gonna they're gonna dress i feel
more comfortable coming here dressed in
whatever i want to wear
than i would and there's there's another
lifestyle couple friend of mine that
i've known for
years and they made the comment to me
one time
my wife and i prefer to come to these
places and enjoy
our time and if we choose to plea was
play with someone then we choose to
i he said i can go to the bathroom
and i've been with my you know my wife
all night long people have seen
us there we've been moving around saying
hi i can put my drink down and go to the
bathroom and come back and i know no
one's going to be bothering her
we go to a textile club and the minute
i turn my back there are three people
three guys trying to hit on her and he's
standing
right there that's the difference women
is explained to me from another uh
partner i played with for a few years
can i be derogatory yeah yeah [ __ ]
makes the rules
right they do not feel comfortable right
it's over
now that you tell anybody in the
lifestyle i don't feel comfortable
they will remove that person from your
side if they are being belligerent and
rude
they will remove that person i feel more
comfortable here
allowing myself to speak freely to walk
around i do yoga out here
almost daily ends up my favorite thing
ever i love making yoga oh my god
it's so fun even if you're in the middle
of play even if in this
person if i say stop it stop
stop that is the golden rule if i don't
want to
it ends and i won't have that freedom i
mean i
tried going a couple of times by myself
to some
you know places out in tampa area and it
was
find the nearest table with women and
stand there and go okay pretend to talk
to me because this is not okay and you
know
lurking guy over there is like hey
here's your drink i don't want to drink
i went out and they would they would
come in
and i would escape out the back door and
i'm like i'm done
if it's not in an environment like this
never going out alone you're reminding
me of stuff
yeah so you feel safer at this time i
absolutely feel safer you know what as a
man so do i
what what you just said i completely
forgot about that in the in the
in the normal textile world where we all
pretend like
once it's all monogamous and once you're
with somebody well
that's how it is you go out to clubs out
in the regular world where
everybody's hypocritical and going well
oh my god
you're a cheater and you did this
they're all trying to hit on everybody
when you go out of the clubs and they're
hitting on your wife they're hitting on
your husband
and and it's so weird but
once you evolve if i may to the point
of accepting all this it's then there's
rules
and then there's uh respect and it's
just so much more the lines aren't
blurry no no the lines aren't blurred
the lines are
if somebody is not okay it stops you
openly communicate
i don't feel comfortable like there's
more openness and honesty
and etiquette because we're not writing
anything
maybe that's it maybe that's it but
really there is an etiquette
in the in the lifestyle i'm not talking
about nudist anymore i'm talking about
lifestyle in
in in the lifestyle world there's an
etiquette
that you just don't experience in the
normal world
and everybody's like a swinger like if
you go to a regular
guy comes up to you and you're just not
interested i mean here
you can let them know and what happens
and right off the bat
if you're good friends and it's like you
know what i'm just not in the mood today
we'll just
hang out and drink and have a good time
yeah there's no judgment i mean
they're okay you know we'll we'll so i
have some friends that i hang out with
and we are just completely open
sometimes we want to play and sometimes
we don't
if we're in a textile environment it's
really funny because everyone's like
oh my goodness they're just we're just
so close and
we'll grab or touch or whatever and we
joke
but the understanding is we're just
hanging out as friends today
or and it's it's nice there's
difficulties but sometimes it's
confusing
sometimes like really even just with you
can you can be
lifestyle oriented couple with life
oriented couple friends and and and
somebody asks you to come over for
dinner and you go
well that's when you say okay do i need
to bring any exercise
or is this just dinner it's like okay we
got the kids this is no tournament
and sometimes you think it's going to be
wild and it isn't yeah oh yeah
there's never any expectations it's come
over
and meet and if we have fun we have fun
if we don't we had to go well we're
going to right we're going to have fun
either way but
what kind of fun yeah excellent well
hunt and yvonne thank you so much for
enlightening us about this lifestyle
i still want to make out with you right
now
[Laughter]
i prefer women but i'm a lesbian by the
way
all right so you guys have never swung
together oh no we've
just i've only around and i think you
just started working here too didn't you
i just started working here last week so
i thought you guys just met on this
interview
we're just oh this is the first time
this is our first time we've sat next to
each other and had a conversation yeah
but i've seen him around yeah excellent
thank you so much you guys
thank you very interesting all right
thank you
you